as an actor I always come in so open and
willing and devoted I really think you
know the intensity of the work and the
relationship requires the devotion and
requires the ability to be malleable yet
to still speak up and not be sort of a
doormat but also adapt so much of it is
adapting because they're all different
and trying to come in there with what I
do which is I bring my emotions and my
ideas but then I'm in your world and I
want to help create your world and I
want to tell your story let's go I'm a
character I was trained as a character
actor that's what I want to do I believe
in changing the way you look the way you
move the way you speak I'm not great at
playing myself so what really gives me
the greatest satisfaction is changing
into something else and I just recently
worked with Jane Campion again on top of
a lake and she's known me since I was 14
and we would we go on long walks
together and she said to me she said you
can do it she said you can keep going
just be bold keep choosing really bold
statement characters because that's what
you're best at and I was like wow okay
that's a particular form of advice you
know and probably not the same advice
she gives some other actress like like
what is the master probably it says
something different to but that and I
listened to Jane I've always listened to
Jane so I'm on a mission for bold
statement characters I grew up with
parents that were I had a biochemist
father and a nurse mother but they were
academics both of them they wanted to
have me following some sort of footsteps
they would have loved medicine
and I said Darwin or action and that was
when I was you know knee-high to a
grasshopper so I think I I define it as
it's just part of my DNA it didn't I
have no one in the family that's an
actor I'd have no idea how it happened
but it's just always been there and I
would read plays books stories
everything like I would just absorb them
from the age of about you know seven or
eight and that's publicly what I call
it's in your blood I was raped on
pantomimes because we're in Australia
and I would see sort of that the
broadness of those pantomimes but I
would laugh and I would see the reaction
in the audience but I would also be able
to get lost in characters when I would
read a novel and it was almost like my
that I wanted to have that life so in
that sense it was that ability to go ah
I actually can have that life if I read
this book and it lasts long enough I can
exist as Natasha and war and peace for a
period of my time on this earth I can
now move over and you know I've moved
into plays I could be Nina in a seagull
and I could be her and that was what was
so appealing I think because I was a
Gorky you know teenager when I and it
was my way of morphing into being
somebody else
I've been unbelievably fortunate to have
great mentors all the women in my life
who have stepped up and mothered me at
different times when I've needed it and
then directors who have just gone out on
a limb to fight for me for a role when
nobody else wanted me yeah I've just had
a lot of good fortune like that and I
give it back I really try to give it
back I mean I I started going to drama
school when I was 14 so I knew how to
prepare texts and things and I'd done
all sorts of mime classes and
improvisational classes so I'd done a
lot I'd sort out classes and you know
the inner city of City
in places in warehouses I just wanted a
place to go my school didn't really
offer the arts so I had to go and find
it so by the time I came to audition I
was so sort of free with that stuff and
I didn't I mean I wanted to get it but
if I wasn't going to get it I was like
I'm I'm going to keep doing this it
doesn't matter if I get the role or not
get it I'm going to keep doing it and I
was lucky because I had people like
Terry Hays and George Miller and Phil
moist John baigan these people got
behind me and believed in me and wrote
roles for me and dead calm actually was
written for me and at 19 that's kind of
amazing so my audition things were more
when I was 14 15 16 I was auditioning
for things and some I'd get some I
wouldn't but that's when I really met a
lot of the big people in the Australian
film industry at that time and a lot of
them just supported me in you know there
was Mel Gibson and there was Judy Davis
and they and they were in a generation
about me and then suddenly there was me
and they were they got behind me I'm
there to be molded do what you want with
me change me make me into something
different and I love that you know and
and so I really relish when a director
goes and Jane you know come on she went
we're going to have grey hair and
freckles and at this she and at peace
you know do this house like yes and even
photograph 51 which is it was Michael he
it completely changed my structure and
and and Christopher did and they first I
think they were thinking I was going to
book at that but I was like no please do
what you need to do and I'll do the rest
from inside and physically you know how
I walk and move and react to my
environment but I need all of that help
that boldness and the courage that you
have and the bravery you have when
you're first starting is the thing that
if you can keep it gives you the most
extraordinary opportunities in career
it's so easy to lose it because you get
safe and scared and you know and lazy
but if I can stay in that place of
bravery and hunger then then who knows
where I'm going to go and that's
exciting to me I don't want to know
[Music]